hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to Friday the 13th killer
puzzle now if you remember a game called
slay away camp this is very very similar
one might say that there is even
something to be said about it being cop
I don't know but either way this is a
different one filled to the brim with
more more adorable murders so for those
of you who are asking for more slay away
camping there were a lot of you now
comes Friday the 13th to make all your
nightmares come true whoo super max
Jason OH
frozen Jason zombie Jason aqua Jason
Funland Jason apocalypse Jason uber
Jason Baghead Jason Ripper Jason
medieval Jason caveman Jason retro Jason
flaming Jason slit af indeed electrical
Jason bloodbath Jason cyber Jason or 3
Jason to execution ok oh I see it's if
this game is free it is free but I'm
guessing it as in-app purchases
quote-unquote which is very weird
considering I'm on Steam right now but
let's get into it
with classic Jason Oh No
you're all doomed you're all adorable in
this boy drowning Crystal Lake because
they can't counselors weren't watching
them in the following days they started
to die one by one
Oh wrong no were murdered by the boy's
mother Pamela Voorhees whoa oh man
cut off her head to stop her now where
son Jason stalks these woods seeking
revenge for her death wait yeah didn't
you drown as a kid maybe I'm not telling
it right what loan all bring it on argh
Gor please avert your eyes avert your
poor virgin eyes cover your virgin ears
just take it all away all right ah yes
the most of the occasion sweetie you
must avenge me use arrow keys gamepad a
drag your mouse to move in this all
right well I guess we'll go this way and
group I don't like the way you shouted
that to the heavens
[Music]
[Laughter]
such nasty nasty campers slide on over
there to punish them Jason right mom
you got it mom I hope you're proud of me
mama hope you're proud right Oh
[Applause]
yeah this is very much like the old horn
or grow okay oh yeah oh boy kill zone
incoming oh I'm sorry oh man I bet
there's a ton of custom animations for
this and I love that out of the punish
them for what they did you Jason for
what they did to me kill from Manor
okay MA okay Bob you gotta mom sorry my
mom told me to listen when my mom tells
me oh boy a girl wins final boy final
girl why do they run from you you're
such a special boy and today's your
birthday my mom would you get me mom did
you give me anything man wait it's a
Trixie's never mind it was totally not a
Trixie why is the girl dazed and
confused
[Laughter]
but it's adorably hearted but also oh
man we're moving fast on this one
remember Jason if you ever need help you
can always dab me for a hint thanks mom
don't be afraid to take the long way
around Jason thanks mom I got it I'm
going the long way around
[Music]
no fine oh boy this is what I was always
waiting for your comments our own
[Music]
horrible you've been doing such a good
job sweetie
here's an extra blood lust now go get
him
thanks mom oh it's what I've always
wanted
whoa what right my dippy toffee Wow rang
oh it's a lo my got a cruller how does
this mean I get more more Co Oh more
kills please yes see how they've run at
the sight of blood kill them jason do it
for mother oh boy all the crowbars gonna
do for you
[Music]
okay we gotta unlock all the animal
nations cabin cleaver
oh those filthy little campers how dare
they try to hurt my special boy I'm okay
MA hahahahaha I'm okay MA
my it's not a big deal mom I mean I'm
fine honestly ma hang on I'll get there
eventually not something to get excited
about
[Music]
how's that even possible in direct hit
okay all right then well then be careful
around the lake Jason you're not a
strong swimmer okay mom
Jason kill the nasty camper from behind
please mom oh yeah
I'll show you Oh oh it was a trick mom
mom oh no mom
[Music]
she's so perturbed press that button
dibs restart the level all right mom
okay mom I won't fall for their dirty
tricks this time don't worry mom I got
this hang on little there we go final
ball you can run from Jason whoa oh good
blood Redman tippy-top you okay thank
you
basement dweller have I told you how
special you are Jason you're very
special thanks mom
thank you who's my sneaky sneaky boy if
you don't let them see you they won't
run away oh no they ran hang on mom
let's go back you can't see me right
apparently you can't see me oh I wonder
what PG mode could possibly be I gotta
go see that you've been doing such a
good job sweetie it's the max of
bloodlust now go get him
thanks mom thank you
i unlock what do I get what special tool
do I get for those special boy
you mean like clue I get to kill someone
with a candlestick incinerator okay
cry mom you can scare those campers into
the fire Jason punish them for what they
did right on mom
right on well that worked out awfully
nice what happens if I go in spooky oh
okay all right here we go foolish fool
why Doughboy rules my back boy here
comes the candlestick
that's not that would work I don't know
too much about murdering with
candlestick that might not be it
be careful Jason if you get stuck use
the rewind button to start over oh it's
a trick
I don't trick what I see one that's a
trick huh
Bobo get your final boy can't get the
SPECIAL boy too smart for you happened
with a candlestick
all right the water's edge no one's
gonna get the SPECIAL boy don't forget
you to change your weapon sweetie use
the weapon icon in the bottom corner
thanks Bob unlock some deadlier weapon
sweetie drag three you don't want to the
trade slot okay mom old truck now one
this one does this trade that up Oh Bob
out up by
perfect all right here we go this is fix
chest this is all what should be the
machete but it's not for some reason
this is the last one Jason vengeance is
yours
yeah mommy wants you to drown this nasty
camper scare him from behind thanks mom
will do mom don't you worry about a
thing
really whoa whoa wait a minute wait he
can swim Oh
oh yeah everything's fine just go back
it's all good
oh boy Oh No oh hello oh my god there's
so many levels orange is the new dad or
[ __ ] yeah I wanna keep playing
holy [ __ ] this is awesome I love this Oh
I unlike Superman he's not locked in
here with you you're locked in here with
him oh hell yeah oh this game is awesome
it's getting free too
you should play this oh wait hot wait
okay oh damn it oh no he's gonna murder
everybody Oh time for a prison break
Jason don't let the guard stop you so if
he gets me I'm guessing that's a bad
now how are they beating jason raize
[ __ ] criminally criminal scum stop right
there criminal scum all right fine but
ya got him whoops oh now there we go no
boy and girl or your machete there if
it's a free tip he's happy to beat that
boom whoa I'll take that yeah I'll take
that I'll stab someone through the GUI
do with that or are you bastards they
never should have found you guilty Jason
you're acting in self-defense
Roy mom you mean to tell me Jason
there's a movie out there where Jason
was put on trial is that actually I have
not seen all the Jason movies so I have
no idea is that actually a thing or is
this just business is here oh wait a
minute I can't go that way
oh I see ah that's a good educational
began Oh
Bogg all right here sonny jim long
oh I don't have to kill the guards oh
well that's easy then oh wait look this
is like what we're gonna do there Jason
listen I was wrongly convicted - hi I
also have some murderous tendencies I
I once stubbed my toe while I was at the
pool when the lifeguard wasn't looking
so I know exactly what you're feeling
here J so long blitz I don't want to
bump I think this guy was trying to get
away from you watch out for those holes
all right mom you got it mom I gotta go
the long way no picnic hmm seems too
easy
be careful Johnson Johnson be careful
joss whedon you don't have much time
before the SWAT team arrives all right
mom hmm let me funcle' about this King
Gotham all right enough God a god a god
mom oh it's obvious now God um
[Music]
sitted oh boy
Bleacher pass all right Oh use the
scroll wheel to zoom in and out and
might give you a new angle on the
situation all right okay
not that I need one but I do spree she
ate that easy-peasy
[Music]
Oh easy peasy lemon squeezy okay wait
it's good I almost want to put money
into this you've been doing such a good
job here so bloodied your head oh thanks
mom
thank you mom thanks mom click guitar
cackles Luke
oh yeah let's do can you bench guards
down all right
those gods look dangerous maybe don't
fight them face-to-face sweetie
how can one card I mean admittedly
admittedly I mean I'm sure it's possible
but it just doesn't seem likely that a
single guard is gonna be able to do much
of anything all right
I think II funcle' finkl finkl thunk
yeah there we go
that's the goods oh oh [ __ ] did he does
Wow like a new battle meatloaf Monday oh
that's not is to make meatloaf for you
Jason
do you remember such a sweet boy yum
yummy yummy in my tummy mom yum yum yum
yum yum yum yum yum yum in the yum yum
oh oh wait a minute hang on now I think
I done goofed a lot ah I got scared then
kill him then kill yo
very scary Jason horrible bullski blam
oh boy
see I don't think you can do that with a
canoe paddle like I get it Ben you're
strong but you seem to be taken down by
simple Guardsmen oh oh they're really
protecting them
ma how can I help you sweetie oh well
thanks mom I thought I was gonna get
another snarky you know response but
barely Bob Oh death row this doesn't
look like the way out Jason keep looking
okay Bob all right listen up guys
my mom's watching and I don't want you
to embarrass me Oh everyone beyond their
best we will have you walk a labem
that'll make you think twice about this
monkey monkey monkey okay and the final
kabuki all right no no no hang on hang
on hang on hang on hang on no this is
not what I want how do I let's let's go
back to the beginning I know this one
here we go
oh wait
that doesn't help either oh okay all
right slow motion I realized I did
something wrong but something tells me
that slow motion what's supposed to be
more interpolated hang on I know all
right watch this we need to kill him
here it's just this one guy this is what
every time I killed this one guy it goes
absolutely bananas for it okay all right
well there you go
one for you it's never as intricate for
the okay it's never as intricate for
that guy it's always that one guys look
at this what clock clock click clock a
tome I get to hit him with a book all
right I guess knowledge is power
come wanna get your gotcha
take my book get ready for a book I'm
really gonna book it to you walk ah bah
you gotta read your Bach I was really
gonna book them god damnit
administration extermination okay I
wonder what you did no oh wait a minute
blob long
Oh No wait a minute
oh here we go I got a black book butter
sticks oh you're not gonna miss out on
this book now there you go what the oh
my god that had nothing to do with the
book I told you I was gonna book him and
then you did nothing with the book you
could have done that with your bare
hands which isn't it that is a weapon by
the way that is a weapon I should use
that one this this guy first this guy's
got to go first okay actually no no it
doesn't what am I saying what am I
saying was that leg first oh my god I
think the book is as if he has his bare
hands no book you can't do that with the
book use maximum security oh here we go
don't let them keep you locked up Jason
you're not the one that belongs in that
chair okay Bob
all right did that did your proud mama
all right there we go murder excellent
weld on me all right let's see what we
got here hmm
a conundrum well this is uh pretty
pickle but I'm a smart little ski
let's start over there we go this is the
one where go got it slam in my face into
the wall a few times a little breakdown
let's never hurt nobody
I gotta say
lemme consol by manual yep I'm boned
from God sorry
this one's a toughy this is a toughy but
I can do it because of my big brain did
I mention I have a big brain did I
mention I have a huge throbbing brain
all right okay ah yeah that's how you do
it yeah you gotta get that guy first and
then you can go back now I got your
number Boyle now I got your number oh oh
no this doesn't seem like a good thing
oh boy oh sorry about the step there I
don't know I had to go all the way
around to get you but yeah okay all
right then well this is what you get for
saying I'm guilty of murder I won't have
my good name disgraced okay it's funny
yeah I'm gonna set it to go PG yeah I
just want to see what did what it's like
I just want to see you know oh yes yes
froze Oh Jase oh hell yeah a
cold-blooded murder machine coming out
of the deep freeze I just want to see
what Petey's like crystal egg ski resort
to open all right what do you got what
are you okay that's weird
oh oh that's PG a fountain of blood I've
got a ski pole see those outhouses Jason
you're a strong boy I bet you can dip
them right over yeah mom I love a good
prank
warm sweet okay
portal girl all right let's see what PG
violence's
[Music]
I guess it's not worth considering
there's no blood but what they just
explode into a happiness cloud is that
what they do
wait Kiki Kiki me chee-chee-chee
is that what it is I love that that's a
feature I'll see what we gotta do here
is a gotta be sneaky that's exactly what
I wanted god oh man oh god oh man
final person final person final person
don't want to assume anyone's gender
okay I don't want to go I don't want to
be offensive when I'm murdering people
click-clack I already have okay all
right thanks anyway that is Friday the
13th killer puzzle for all I know this
is made by the same people that made
slave camp because they're startling ly
similar so if they're not made by the
same person then oopsy poopsy but still
it's a fun game so if you like this
puzzle stuff and you like seeing a bunch
of horrible murder and adorable
animations check it out for yourself
I'll put a link in the description thank
you again let me know he thought down
the comments below and as always I will
see you in the next video
[Music]